how's it going guys just want to show
you some updates on the game engine i've
been working on ancient archer it's just
an open glc plus plus game engine so
we're going to take a look at some code
and uh just go over the changes and i'm
also going to talk about future plans so
if you're interested in and all this
just stick around there's links down
below to the code and the source all
open source you can see the changelog
all that good stuff all right let's jump
into the changes and let's talk some
code and game engines
build three third semi-official release
i'm calling them a pre-release i just
wanted to get a release system going
and a versioning system going because i
hadn't been doing that when i was just
tinkering around you know this is an old
engine from back in my college days when
i was in my first opengl and graphics
course
all right so let's talk about these main
changes here well i've added a few
things you know i was messing with
adding a little gooey system
and now i added the ability for them to
be textured or colored i also refactored
how the shaders and lights work in the c
plus side and i turned on the alpha on
the textures and i added some settings
just maximizing v-sync just some screen
settings stuff
and i refactored the whole engine
initialization and i
fixed in the shaders some object
positioning calculations and normal
position calculations
uh some that probably shouldn't have
been broke to begin with something i
just overlooked but hey shaders and
lighting is a lot of complicated stuff
and in the dark launch section these are
just stuff that's behind the scenes not
really publicly available so if you use
it you won't really see these
that's pretty much what dark launch
means i've added i and gui behind the
scenes
so there might be some front end coming
for that if i don't use my own custom
interface all the time so yeah i started
out in the custom interface and i was
like why not i am gooey so yeah they're
both in there and i added some animation
code i was trying to get animations
working for some bass cases and it
didn't quite work out yet but we're
getting closer there's a bunch of code
in there most of it originated from
learn opengl but it seemed like it was
pretty buggy the way they had it so it's
not really going to work completely as
is anyway
and or maybe i did something wrong so uh
there's still a lot of work to do there
but if you compile your
notice a bunch of warnings from it and
last but not least the other changes
just some smaller stuff i worked on the
camera class
some i made the interface use an
internal shader i used to have interface
shader now it's just all contained so
you won't even see it i added a scene
and model check utility just something
that
reads the model and kind of tells you
about it some basic stuff like that
and i made some changes to demo apps
which we'll see and i refactor the
timing uh the timing's actually the same
i just used glfw timers instead of
chrono it just seemed a little more
lightweight already had glw already in
the
engine and everything and just adding
chrono is kind of like doubling up the
same thing so i just got rid of one of
them and
i also was kind of messing with the
textures and stuff and notice they're
not exactly working right with the thong
lighting stuff
so it's diffuse only right now which is
should be temporary but that's just kind
of how i left it uh i'm kind of working
on a deadline system it's really been
like a couple months since build two so
i really need to get bill 3 out
and i want to do these on a more stable
basis if i'll get to the if that'll be
the future
so let's go ahead and run it and see
what that looks like all right so if you
haven't seen
any of the previous episodes well
basically you just open the solution
with visual studio installed libraries
everything's in the readme i don't want
to talk about that too much but i'm
going to run this example project here
and it's close the same as before but
you'll notice some differences uh
currently i only have a flashlight
so it's not super strong and turn it on
and off as you can see the lighting is
staying
on him as it should and moving as he
moves or whatever it's
i guess what i'm trying to say is
previously the lighting like sucked
it was weird it was the normal maps that
were messed up so uh for the normal
calculation so fixing that the lighting
should all work better uh i think
there's only a flashlight but also
there's point lights and directional
lights and they should all work good but
this is just a quick little sample so
that's really it for that i kind of
started messing around with the idea of
making an editor but that didn't get
included i don't know if i'm going to go
forward with that
as i talk about future plans you'll see
why awesome you made it this
far if you could like like the video and
stuff just for the youtube algorithm i
hate saying this but
i guess i kind of have to say it it's a
youtube thing so uh
yeah it would just mean a lot and if you
want to follow this project more you can
start there and follow it over there
because i do work on it pretty routinely
basically just see this whole list of
stuff since version o2 here
and uh yeah there's been quite a few
commits but really i've been not working
on this very
diligently and because i have my reasons
i have a lot of other interests and
stuff
so sometimes this gets put on the back
burner or when i get stuck on something
it gets frustrating like the animation
stuff i worked on that for like two
three weeks straight and when it didn't
work and i couldn't get it to work
i was just kind of done and i just had
to stop and walk away or change
direction so
i've gotta uh kind of rethink that a
little bit because that's not a good
coding habit you don't want to get
yourself in a situation where you're
frustrated and feel like you want to
stop
that's really that's kind of the
important lesson i've learned here and
all right i'm going to go to the
announcement section of this video
announcement section so i guess there's
a couple
announcements here um oh yeah the
bounties before the announcements the
bounties yeah i brought this up last
time i'll talk about it a little more so
on this repo
if you go to projects there's a bounty
board and you basically just have to
make a full request that solves some of
the stuff but uh
i don't know i just kind of initialized
it with some kind of low numbers you
know for the bounty numbers because
well hey i'm not rich andy i don't know
i kind of was hoping to get a little
feedback but basically nobody really
said anything
so i don't really know what to think i
was thinking of maybe doubling the
bounty price and maybe that or the
bounty reward
and maybe that would get some attention
i don't know i i can't tell if people
are just like i don't care what the
price is that's just too hard or what i
have no idea but i don't know
i don't really know how to properly ask
for help because i don't like asking for
help without having some way
you know hey or something i don't know
it's weird so this bounty board is just
up in the air if you want to work on
them awesome uh as long as it's up here
i'll
you know i'll pay you whatever it's
worth but at some point i think i'm
going to take down this bounty board
because i've started to realize you know
as i get more seasoned with this stuff i
kind of realize that i can
implement these without that much
trouble now if i really just commit the
time i just haven't committed a whole
lot of time
to them is what it comes down to and
i'll get those screenplay that's cool um
so i don't know
you could if you guys could like just
give me any feedback on how to
uh ask people to you know if you could
implement this i'll pay you this type of
thing i don't know it's just not working
with this bounty board no one seemed
interested at all um
there's even one that's like i don't
know they're not super expensive like 50
bucks 50 bucks 125
25 like some of these are really easy
like this music looping one it's
probably like one line of code honestly
or two lines
uh and and all of this stuff has really
easy
tutorials all over the place for it so
or not i don't
easy's not the right word they're just
plain there's plenty of documentation
for how to do all this
so i don't feel like it's super hard
like if someone just knew where the code
was i could literally just copy paste it
over and throw it in there real quick
and it would probably work that's why
it's one of the reasons i didn't make
the bounty super high is because i know
that none of these take like
unique uh new groundbreaking code it's
all just kind of copy pasta
type stuff since it's already well known
no need to reinvent the wheel all right
now to the announcements
all right i guess the big thing is i as
a lot of you may know i'm really
interested in game development but i
haven't really made a proper game i made
a lot of demos
made a lot of little things a lot of
tools i haven't made like a proper game
with a proper release with like
you know a steam release page you know
all that stuff that you want for a game
word even a niche page or anything like
that
so i really really really want to get
down to brass tacks and do it i know you
know i've read a lot about the subject
people say just join
a game jam some reason you know i tried
i joined one and i had like no
motivation to work on
the game jam at all so i don't know that
just doesn't motivate me for some reason
but
getting to like write my own story and
do things my own way
and just implement all these algorithms
and code sounds really fun to me so that
like motivates me more than a game jam
for some reason so anyway long story
short i pretty well settled upon the
game design of something i really want
to make
i don't think it's too hard it's kind of
hard but you know i don't want to just
make like a quick
something i want it to actually be
something i'm passionate about so i
don't know if i'm going to use
this engine ancient archer or if i'm
going to use some other engine but i'm
pretty sure what's actually going to
happen
is while the other announcement this
engine's probably going to cancel out at
least this branch of it i think that
it's time for me to rewrite this whole
thing all
a lot of this code is like super old
when i'm trying to reason about it it's
very over complicated
and i just feel like i need to start
over i need to take it from scratch and
understand everything
because there is definitely mountains
and mountains of code at this point and
when i'm trying to figure
stuff out and figure out how it's
looping and where i should throw in
things it takes me way longer than it
should so i feel like if i just step
back and start fresh
just pull the pieces i need out of this
one piece at a time and kind of
reorganize it a better way and you know
it is due time too they say you do need
to rewrite uh
way it varies but i think it's a good
three to five years and i'm in that i'm
probably in the three year at this
uh given that i started in college i
might even be long i don't know i'd have
to like go look at eight stamps to
really figure out but i am at the point
where rewrite is in order so it does
make sense for me to go ahead and start
rewriting this engine and
i don't know if i'm gonna call it
ancient archer two i don't know if i'm
just going to up the version i think i'm
just going to up the version
so about the name i'm not real set on
the name the name was just like
whatever came to my head at the time i
started making it basically and it was
of the idea of
you know like the physics of archery and
also like kind of just a pun
i'm taking a shot at this and uh ancient
because i felt like i was using ancient
technology like i was starting out with
opengl and i was like i know there's
like better stuff i should probably use
directx and even vulcan was coming out
at the time
so yeah i just named it ancient archer
because and also i
really wanted to make like an archery
game at the time and i kind of did it
was for one of my old projects in school
um i wonder if i have a version of that
somewhere it might be interesting to go
over my really old
projects from school at some point and
then do a video on them and see
how bad my code was from back then or
whatever let me know what you guys think
about that sort of thing would be i feel
like it'd be fun and interesting but i
don't know how much people would
actually want to watch
that sort of thing so yeah rewrite and i
think on the rewrite
that's probably what i'll make the game
on you know i thought about making the
game on unreal on unity on godot
and i feel like i'm always very annoyed
when i use those engines
because i can't do all the like really
fine grain stuff without digging into
their systems and how they've abstracted
so i'd rather just have raw access to
the data and the code and be able to do
my own thing that way i feel like i'm a
lot more comfortable
uh writing applications that way i don't
really like using
too heavily over the hood tools i'm not
one of those no code movement type type
guys i love code i want to see a lot of
code and uh someone else that's not
interested in code can do the whole no
code thing all right well
yeah i guess that's pretty much it uh
thanks for watching and i appreciate you
guys
a huge shout out to my patrons uh for
this month you guys have
helped me a lot it just means a lot just
to like know that people are willing to
back me up and help me keep making these
silly code videos and empowering someone
that otherwise is just you know kind of
like doing their own thing
chilling at home and and working on code
all right
i don't know how to say thanks that's
basically what it comes to but thanks i
i do appreciate it and if anyone else
wants to sign up for next month you can
get on the list
and uh get a little more access to me
and all that stuff sure hit me up or
he joins also a discord so you can jump
on discord if you want to talk about
code and stuff all right i'll see you
guys in the next one thanks for watching
and peace out
[Music]
so
you